all right hello you guys I'm back again
for some more knockouts um I think on
the past I played a mix of strong
players and we players today I think I'm
going to try and make a run at 3000 if
it's possible so I'll probably six
playing most of these top guys here if I
get the chance so let's see like let's
see I'll try and chop some of these guys
like Renato bono leus people along these
lines and see how it goes and go from
there um so let's let's see let's see if
anybody's gonna accept wow I guess
they're knocking except right now let's
see um who else is in let's see maybe
there's one with this Spartacus guy um
[Music]
Bracken maybe ok so here we go ok so
I'll start with playing us guys Michela
Bracken play to be on some one of these
other times as well so so let's see I'll
start with him I will occasionally pay
attention to the chat today I'm like
last couple of times so um so if you
have questions go ahead and feel free to
ask them I'll try and put screens every
so often when I when I'm not not playing
so it's off you guys said a way to smash
Hampton yesterday yeah it was a lot of
fun actually
um I played both him and Robin van cam
from the previous day I think they're
both at the same location right now I
think they're both in Montreal I did
better against um against Eric nighted
against Robin I still do quite well
against Robin as well but I really
really a hammered Eric so I'm a little
bit bad for him but the thought goes
sometimes so alright so clean v3 clean
b6
now I know there's some trick efficiency
- I think I'm supposed to take here and
play like a c5 does not count remember
right also I'm just going to play normal
Moodle clip this would be 297 just count
long probably Queen c2 and maybe h3 fish
would be 3
ten pound on the brakes normally Locke
will take on c4 and then play for c5 or
5 so Duty is going to do all right
so okay so castle is now I'm going to
draw my Queen back to see to try and do
something here on the Queen side maybe
see you see what he wants to do
basically as I said before black almost
always going to try to take on c4 at
some point but I guess in this case he
doesn't want to so I'm going to play c5
probably those Oh Queen C so I'm going
to play upward trying restrict all's
activity here are no e5 grapes
he doesn't something like Knight g4 I
suppose picking up a pawn
possibly I'm not completely clear what
that does okay so someone just to ask do
you know when you're playing as Magnus
secret accounts um I can't say for sure
that I I know when when I'm playing it's
one of those accounts but I will say
that in regards to that normally I can't
sense when I'm playing at someone who's
quite good like I won't be able to know
it's magnets or someone else but
generally um generally I'll have it all
pretty good feels there's something
there's something slightly off with one
playing and so I won't be certain of
food is but awesome some sort of spider
sense that it's someone this someone's
good let's just split let's put it that
way so back to the game positions gone
blocking on the Queen sides but with
both or the king side that actually said
it was both of our kings over here on
the Queen side on there definitely
should be some fireworks
so please 94 I can take I think I'm just
going to retreat to Bishop protect the
pawn here on g3 I think let's say I'll
play a three just cautious moves
probably Knight g4 is what he'll do I
just want to play some simple shots take
with the Queen play like Queen b3 I just
want to put a 4 B 5 something on line to
the Kings Indian maybe I'll take on e4 2
because he can't take it too deep on
since this pawn here on e6 would hang so
let's see maybe he'll probably play I
know you can need to play B 6 a 6 he's
going to play Kings feet and try to run
away now which i think is a little bit
ill-advised because after b5 I'm going
to control all the breaks here so I'm
gonna play rook c1 just to stop any b6
nonsense plays work al me
he wants to play a s6 a little bit
unclear I'll just play public King a
tooth once the a tooth I'll just take on
c6 so you can review so I will play now
he's trying something over here on the
queenside b6 is not a threat ASIC still
is single place an appropriate lactic or
q1 played for some G for pawn break and
we'll see maybe g4 here is a move on 16
f7 and so now I've got to figure out how
I'm going to break it so I can take on
f5 that's one move but I think hopefully
works me to what the idea is doubling on
the G file and maybe threatening to take
up five and then put pressure on g7 and
I can get this work here so he goes back
for KJ and now I kind of decision time I
can play g5 I'm not really crazy about
it I could play with you two actually
looks reasonable could not be takes all
I'll take so he plays they're tough six
now let's see now here I can take on e4
not take I think I'm going to take on e4
and hope he takes what I took with a
deep on here
I think charge and go h5 so now when he
takes h5 I take up five and I got this
awesome
you can't take backside got the 10 so
I'm starting to just like break all this
whole constructs about to piss like
collapse pretty much instantly so so
work up eight so what if you've really
kind of put his king on a well he's
gonna have to take it the king but after
King g6 just Queen e6 I think it's just
winning I mean I can probably also have
to change e6 just taking or you goes
tini seven I think I've G 500 equals
King e8 okay now two pawns
I'll just take on C so excited to open
up a B file I could take play work up
stick so I'm simply g5 to make sure
there are no work up six ideas and
surely this has to be winning south over
p2 or p7 okay so those would be eight
like taking play with each one
in age seven or qi8 okay so he's trying
to hold on
actually I don't have much time so I got
a little quickly
I had Ricky yeah Ricky seven and Ricky
5gt can play rook e8 for this town but
I'll just play like this and and I mean
there is no way he'll survive this so
[Music]
yeah now I resigned
okay so I'll play them again see so
probably d4l tonight at six
I guess I'll play something different
this time so let's see what let's see
what he wants to do oh oh
Bishop g5 normally he plays playing c4
not an e4 now this is a recalls not
normally usually isolate III and c4 he's
going to play Bishop III probably Knight
f3 maybe 92 pretty standard so far
nothing nothing to create this time I'm
gonna play c5 trying try and change the
structure a little bit here maybe c3
Queen b6 or something along those lines
um so okay so let's say so I just saw
there's some comment so I'm gonna get
text went in for a second
castles 96 maybe a city okay so let me
just add white wine why not why why why
not two nights tango I'll keep that in
mind I'll I'll put a two night tango got
someone at a later point on the screen
um so I will keep that in mind so I'm
going to break the structure here
basically defy the wanting to take that
at some point I can play up five and
free this fishable on this long diagonal
here also a nice b4 attack DSS so how
many goes there should be four off again
with a five on Bishop c4 all this take
and again I just want to go up five and
just you know open up clean b3 is
probably a bad notes after Knight b6 I
probably have to retreat the bishop and
I'll go Bishop e6 hitting as clean on b3
if I can get this but so risky one I'll
take probably hopefully 94 and not to be
a little bit careful Bishop e6 d5
five d5 Bishop d5 I think I'm okay sir
if you please piece five maybe not but
it looks reasonably okay so he's please
clean before now so they should be
slides to take this night here on earth
three probably he'll maybe play 92 maybe
we'll play an ID three anyway I a little
bit weird to do but it's possible the
study can roll this pawn right down sure
enough he does it click when you sub and
protect this pawn here on b7 probably d5
and I'll play rook e8 just want to go
like fish buffets this would be 6
something like this or maybe even just
f5 it's also completely fine so it plays
d6 I think I'll play work b5 probably do
something here try and create some
triathlon in between you know you know
it's Kings a little bit open here so
maybe play for up to 5 or cleaning H 3
Queen h2 reaction might be a serious
threat they won't be able to block me to
corpse there will be like a rook to 5
pin on it King
so repeat 5 um thanks someone just said
I'm really articulate that's funny to
hear uh anyway work d5 I'll play play up
5 I think I'm going to try to keep keep
all the pieces on the board here maybe
repeat this probably is a bad mistake
Brooksie 100 d8 probably fish buffeted
at some point up 5 just basically trying
to put pressure on this deep on until I
decide what I'm actually doing so so
we'll see um nice before I'm going to
play b6 just stop any Knight a5 nan so
it's basically just restrict everything
here and now he's not actually trying
anything to know I need to do something
so maybe f5 Bishop f8 sandals um I think
there's stuff 8 8 5 is kind of an issue
here so I think I'm just going to play
work c8
it's a b3 finger stuff fate
this might have been slightly wrong so
now I know I guess to exchange the
Queen's and this isn't quite where I
wanted but at the same time he doesn't
really have much play
either so kind of okay this isn't really
great for this isn't really what I
wanted I don't think this what you
wanted either though so I think a little
bit unhappy should be five and I'll play
up five now maybe have six at some point
if you plays 95 I just take upon not
really sure I'm going to go f-16 up
seven but I think f6 to cover this e5
square make sense now I'll just run the
King over to f76 like two moves and okay
played up for which I think is a mistake
I think I can go rookie for now and I'm
going to take and now I'm just going to
bring my king as close to the staff so I
can over here on and it's pawn on f4
might become a weakness on I put it on
dark square so it can be attacked by the
bishop so it's probably not not not
great um so teeny to elf 1886 now I
don't know if I take king before g5 I
feel like this should be winning okay
how can this not be high this this has
to be winning so um so h4 now I can take
are you play with these five I can also
just play h6 I think h6 is probably the
right move here so he takes I'll take so
probably King before so Kings before so
I can also H 5 H 4 ETH Turing so I think
this has to be went so H 5 which is a
move okay I'll take he goes after I go
Keeney 5 I think
oh gee I just wonder this somehow ah
shoot I just love this click on the draw
hmm I was unfortunate I said it's not a
dumb not oh well anyway
wait is that what it was King b3 dying
hazards on how king D 3 King before if
you accept the triangulation this was
just a draw but now it's not a draw and
my con has to be quicker here so I don't
know what's going to be true was whether
that was just a slip or what that was on
I think maybe if I tried h5 maybe it was
a maybe who's winning so I should have
created outside pawn on ice actually I
see Erica's challenge and I guess he
logged on so he wants he wants more
punishment
so let's what I all claim at some point
not not quite yet I got I got a warm-up
first before I play ok it's a d4 ninety
four fish drop 593 probably Bishop d6 95
more I feel like this is theory somehow
h4 but H 4 H if 95 turns into some weird
line I think on Jackson normally nights
on gg 1 here guy sometime get an extra
comfo 93 maybe I'm just crazy IRA may
just like pause on g4 yeah sorry that's
that's actually the difference it's a
fish fish 7 now I can clean up 3 Knight
f6 Queen b3 maybe that probably works
I mean Queen f3 Knight f6 Queen b3 Queen
d5 takes 25 Bishop e2 e6 it's sharp I'm
going to play something a little bit
we're on play Queen h5 so I'm 25 I can
meet it with Oh an ally is Queen D
fought the Queen d5 maybe Queen 3 maybe
I know what am I thinking I just
exchanged a play Bishop e5 just stupid
what am I thinking
Wow
okay so so what's he going to do okay so
D for all I'll probably play something
similar to last maybe hopefully yeah
this game is awesome to play Bishop g5
on clay groans well to it he has against
this for Bishop e7 e three castles
something random Castle probably
hopefully works e1 and how does this
line go it's going like here since I
played any of the stuff but hopefully 56
55 95 probably he'll take 25 B take some
c7
okay so b3 now why is this not right
somehow b3 is not the move that I'm
useless thing on I could just plain I
see seven maybe play aggressively I
think I will just I'll just Chuck upon
and try to play for some kind counter
play that may or may not exist I'm not
really quite sure so okay so I see a
bunch of people want me to play Erica oh
I'll get to that I'll get to that
so night at 3:00 c5 Bishop c4 is a
problem so insular Brooks CA probably
also deficiency for any way being solids
also on check Queen d2 takes probably 92
or Kingi to 92 I guess I'll take
Fishbach 5 ee 4 was wasn't very good so
next time so I don't know if he'll take
nice before routes before works before
probably 5 played nice before I'll play
c5 anyway probably he'll take maybe d5
d5 Knight f6 and block should be
completed this line here so I cause
Derek companies' 4head parently well he
needs to play more like Rob and then Rob
Robin axe put up a pretty good fight he
got a lot of bad
dishes that were losing but he is very
resourceful and party to the game so you
did a good job so yeah okay so work D
196 maybe I really don't want to do this
guy draw so I'm gonna play Knight up so
to try to play play for more initiative
as castles d5 probably on trying to kick
this Knight kind of trade on c2 if you
please 95 works c2 so so so I don't know
that shrimp seeing some people in the
chat saying that Eric threw a chair um
if he is a hilarious ah poor air poor
air
okay so I'll play work c2 here probably
will play nicely seven I'm not sure yet
so a for I can take I can do something
else is pretty dry though maybe eight
697 rook c8 it's pretty pretty hard to
create something here but I'll try it so
I'll take play work c8
it's a pretty boring position but I do
control the see files are always there
some back ranked tricks long-term a pawn
is a four pawns little bit weaker than
my sub and pawn
also is bishop in its Knight aren't are
ideally placed here okay so Rick P one
logical move um maybe ninety four here
yeah I like 94 threaten this fork also I
threaten g5 winning some material so 94
I like I think it's good move
especially this 92 threat is very
serious Somaly 95 was also possible 95
or 37 was fine but I thought no this is
hard to play Ashe what about it it's not
rookie 7 here
I think I'll just put up 6 2 so that I
can meet rookie some of the e5 and he
goes into 80 for Donald's over okay -
okay so clear up these four so it's an
HP 3 again I want to play e5 at some
point and shutout if they should just
close this whole diagonal to g4 ok e5
probably Bishop g3 I'll click g5 to stop
them from playing g5 and braving the
pawn pawn structure both NIT 5 probably
work b3 and now I'll play I'll play work
c3 here try to force them to exchange
exchange etc works and now the knight
controls this square and this square so
this look this is looking pretty good so
I'll put a 5 make this a long-term
weakness where he can't do anything page
4 h6 will probably take maybe 91 ok
they're going to go team ops 1 I'll play
bishops update try to plant this Bishop
here on b4 d to probably work c1 maybe
there should be 4
I'm essentially the problem here at boy
is this bishop but it's just kind of
like really out of play now so it's
going to be very hard here to define so
I'll say work before pick up this a for
pawn all
to attack this g4 Khan so let's take a
4G before taking to you for was also
completely fine on a 484 credit for
tonight to ask to to close this diagonal
because now after this move the diagonal
shut so I think I will just take and
play Knight to three and now I'm just
running this pawn straight down the
board um King there okay I don't come
all the time in the world so I'm going
to be a little bit careful here probably
King C to always push up onto a tail
ah there should be six very clever very
shaky so hey
o kings III I did not see that incoming
Oh what was that anyway I was all just
flying here this is not how I was hoping
to play this but anyway just have to
avoid a fork and throw in a few more
check
and this should I'll be able to slag in
here and yeah okay so I'll play I'll put
in one more game and then I'll move on
hopefully d4 again probably d5 as usual
alright someone told me to play the two
nights and go earlier so I I'll keep
that in mind for for one of these other
games so just ask would that be a draw
over the board on with a pun on e3 I'm
pretty sure that would be with a pawn on
e4 I'm not I'm not certain I think
probably still is the draw but it would
not be would not be trivial so d6 Castle
probably castle or he'll take so I'll
take castles Queen c2 pretty standard
some kind of Queens Queens Indian
capital T or nitrile t-cells obviously
for anyone probably e5 d5 so I don't
have to play d5 I can let them take
hopefully rook e1 prophylactic just
create a square for this night on f1 so
d5 I have knife 193 right away so a 5
I'll just play d5 no need to wait now
probably nice h5 Wow what is a chive
that's very bold basically says now it's
going to kind of lacks enough problems
cuz he can always Castle kingside both
this pondering h5 a little it's a little
bit weird and so he's basically going
all-in here
so Bishop c8 I don't really understand
where he's going but hopefully h3 just
stop any nonsense over here I'm going to
go a 3 B 4 next moves most likely
and also after okay so he's just he's
just burning all his bridges he just
wants to attack um which is interesting
182 now protect this pawn and not be
four isn't is a very serious threat
basically I didn't learn this 92 earlier
because because I was worrying you place
an h4 move but now now I'm going to go
all-in and just kill them to the Nike
793 maybe you can play King f8 and run
but it's pretty ugly here
so King outfit I'll take 23 probably
Nike 3 next move after team g7 just 93
and push the plate for the c5 pawn break
I also worked up one may be worked up
one a three or a four the many office
here but because he has this weakness
this week square here which you just
overlooked in one move on is always his
issues so it's all right let's get so ok
so let's see okay so I see Erik is
playing so I'll challenge Rijn Renato
maybe Zoran T as well and move maybe
Stein went to see if you want to play
okay if anyone wants to play some okay I
don't know why place opens wasn't really
my intention but anyway not much I can
do about that so play something strange
so I don't know if you're if you're
going to play d4 if you're going to play
something else okay tonight a3 just
develop all my pieces probably dished
off five I want to play b6 of it and
I'll play d4 maybe he'll take maybe he
won't
um it can be seven all capital I
probably want to take care of c5 on at
some point put a three Soph anything on
this be for square and now I would take
so if you take to the bishop I'd be four
so he took the pawn the rook c1 try to
play these got these two pawns here in
the center cleaning seven-digit d3 play
for rook e1 need for if I get the chance
or create will see one maybe ninety four
here
you'll play that
I guess this thing about 94 may be
thinking about 95 94 quality is Queen c2
or Knight up 193 it all depends what we
want to do here not is he flagging is he
thinking okay so say 95 okay so I'll say
I can take I can play Bishop a5 many
different options I think I'll just play
mm-hmm
I think I'll just take and play clicking
c2
so let's see so what's he going to do
here
d4 dubious with the community 7 it takes
I'll just take actually all the
screaming is that just in case he does
it on it maybe sing about c4 I'm not
really sure what he's thinking so long
about here um now I will play there's
about five hit the rook probably work c7
I think I will tape or please yeah I'll
take and I think I'm going to simply be
for now try and create this this
weakness so as his rook is hanging on c7
so you can't take if he pushes who
pushes c4 g6 no I can't take Saul's
retreat to d3 he puts a c4 all denied f3
he is thinking a lot or I've noticed so
I should see what he's going to do um I
expect them to place c4 eventually a d4
is always there
I think it can just take c5 but even if
I can I don't I don't really see what's
wrong with just playing with like efore
here maybe not the best but I'm off a
minute on the clock I don't really see
the point to going into a deep deep tank
so that sort c8 now I think I 94 hit the
Queen we need 7 and I'll play b5 and now
this night on c4 is fantastic to e5 in
g7 so I've 6 or 96 um
I am Not sure I think all play Nikes
let's all play the aggressive move and
also f4 if you move the Nidal class 5
and if he plays Bishop a I mean I could
play outside anyway but I think I don't
really see his clamps understand
flipping off to try shift the Queen to
g3 and put pressure on King so now I
played 96 and now I think he's in real
trouble after off 5 Queen g5 + LH for
probably g4 ok so now I'm up a lot of
time with clocks all positioned before
try to try to exchange this
the ship for that night 95 okay what's
the best move here sighs I think I'll
quit this way yeah there's about three
clean up for G three traps is going and
that should be that should be all G room
so okay so the plan again G for 906 c4
luckily something offbeat I forgot to
keep forgetting that someone told me to
plate it two nights they keep forgetting
that okay next next game against him
next game against this Kyle all all
pleasure two nights tango after I forgot
that I forgot that that I said that's
before so okay so I can be a little bit
careful here I kind of miss played this
opening rather badly I might add salt
take I'll take um let's have some fun
I'll try b5 here
I already butcher the opening badly
enough that I'm just going to try and
help on playing playing interesting
stuff so um let's see what's he going to
do
b3 interesting very interesting it takes
this actually works I'll just take keep
playing simple trust almost council
probably night g27 castles hopefully
nice b6 try to put pressure on the c4
pawn maybe and if you played a three
maybe I'll retreat Bishop a5 maybe not
not actually sure I think hopefully this
basics here
I think he's forgetting on the a3 I
don't actually it's not automatic but I
have to take I can also just retrieve my
bishop here so so so let's slow to it is
going to do it so 94 um okay so now I
can take take take take now if I take
this grave 7 King AJ I don't see it I'm
just going to go for because now I have
93 tricks I mean you can play workup 3 I
suppose I actually didn't see that that
could be a slight issue but let's see
okay so he just find it I'm try to
please I'm trying to make this murky I
want to play community forums act like
weiner I don't know if this works
probably it doesn't but I'm going to try
to make this a little bit weird so I
think we'll see problem probably has
flavor gauge 3 if he plays their space
up 5 I can probably just take the disc
upon V 2
okay so he's plays Bishop d3 so it's he
threatened so if I take on b2
oh we can just take on a6 oh I didn't
see that right off and that was rather
bad okay I'll play him two more problem
is he's so low rated that I'm only
getting two points for a win which is a
little bit ridiculous
so hopefully two more than all place in
with a higher rating on good b5 a 6 ok
so he's going to place one of these
systems I'm going to Spanish fish meat 7
will be one probably be 5 you're going
to keep placing Marshall or not
I have definitely does not so C 3 d6
please
d 454 alpha Bishop e3
so he's going to do cd4 or 84 cd4 defy
this ancient line like this hasn't been
played much in recent years but still up
prominent lines of 5f5 ss5
why don't I remember this line okay um
okay so I can play HTV I just click
Queen d3 here cancer to remember this
this line very well I think I think just
cleaned eternity takes I'll take and
I'll get my king over to h1 so I'll make
that a Prairie move and if he doesn't
take maybe I'll move the knight maybe
not I'm not sure actually Queen d7 okay
now I think I have to play e6 and just
just just takes Bishop g5 try and play
against has all those pieces are kind of
misplace or the fishpond chief or is
weird Bishop from this night everything
is a little bit loose hair and d5 is a
big weakness and you move this Queen
I'll probably play Knight e5 probably if
he doesn't agree take some glowing
vision p5 2695 if he goes Queen d8
probably just about four of this
we took off their g5 Queen b6 so now I
can take I suppose I plate take taking
maybe as rookie seven it looks good
enough take all okay okay play 95 now
I've got a good knighting that's a very
bad Bishop here so I'm just going to
like working one maybe I like cleaning
three but shouldn't really not is the
Queen you typically queen g3 throughout
night up seven and some back rank tricks
threaten to also just take this bishop
so who's going to do here
so bishop h5 that is a move 93 maybe is
up for so I need to keep the pressure on
in here so I'm just going to play how do
I keep the pressure on
so Queen h4 bush ii 8 i'm go play queen
g5 force underneath the bishop now I'll
play nice III and try to put the knight
on this other square here on c5 and play
against his weak palms because basically
I need to bring my queen into the game
nicely Bishop left 7 it's a good move on
now as work e7 h6 inaudible I'm not at
much time around the clock so I was
making quick decisions here um I think
I'll play Knight e5 city takes health a
rock a rock a 1 or or work e7 probably
work a11 makes the most sense
I assume he will take no he's not going
to take okay off the Queen seven
probably bish takes a 290x 86 because
now if you take the night I take his
rook so and I'm also running c7 here too
so we've got six now I can take the pawn
and why not make sense if you take the
cake Queen to sickle track and I will
take the pawn and I should just be up to
haunt here right it takes takes takes
rupees six I've rookie five I've gotten
a little bit mathy but I'm Way up on the
clock here which is very important so I
was paid I ate three efficient d3o there
should be 5 volts ac for takes let's see
one and now I just need to bring three
so it's just a matter of putting
everything on the right squares so now I
put the nyah III now after getting d5 is
now just get over so I just took up the
pick up this pawn here on f5 so alright
so there you go there's the two knights
okay let's who's going to do against it
Knight of three I'll play all display
standard standard to Knight angle here I
could have placed these six also move
all their many options on this play it's
going to end up turning into some kind
Enzo anyway so castle probably a three
I'll play Queen e7 and E 5 I guess to
play a five this acting to turn is
something very similar to what I played
that other game against Mikkel where I
was where I was white um
so let's see okay so he's thinking again
probably v4 okay I will
eight I'll exchange here another couple
ways of playing this I'm going to try
and break the center right away um
basically please b5 he creates a
weakness here on c5 and I'll quit b6 and
Bishop d7 feeandpete on my bishop
potentially probably will play Knight e4
here maybe f4 f4 95 so there should be
seven simple shots then I see five
probably their stuff want there's b2
rook c8 basically I want to play for d5
as well here h3 okay so I can play d5 or
not it doesn't feel quite right I'll
just create a square for my king later
on 93 now I would think and playing
Knight 97 Queen b3 so play 94 cuz I 97
Queen d3 hit this pawn so the night here
at protects the pond clean I see five
probably may turn it into a draw play
work at eight it's pretty pretty Josh I
have to say so maybe I'll play puppet
Queen g5 try and make it interesting at
least so he plays this rough through I
play Knight d5 who plays this I mean I
hopefully clean up six fish 395 too but
maybe clean up six was slightly more
precise than please utilize but the show
goes on
so guys think the questions coming I am
walking periodically at the chat so
let's see okay it's a bish buff one
logical move I could play d5 care takes
rip c3 but I don't see the continuation
I could click Queen h4 I'll try and keep
playing active moves here trying try and
confuse this basically trying to infuse
the matter between b2
um maybe five it just takes rook e8 f
three probably unfortunately turn into
nothingness so I will play enough so it
calls play cleanup success 395 and make
a draw something like that
condition P 3 so he doesn't want to draw
now aqua 95 126 try and put pressure on
this pawn here on g2 94 mean sick so now
I mean I gave me d5 so now it's now it's
not clear at all so s3 I can also move
my knight I can alter this attack this
pawn or maybe Queen g5 I think I'll stay
clean g5 so he takes I take and I take
okay so it takes her on d5 you take some
epon maybe six and now I've got a path
to e pawn so this isn't really clear so
this is going to get double-edged in a
hurry that much is clear so I'm gonna go
Bishop CA now and I gave me for now it's
going to probably end up in a lot of
trouble probably he'll take no he
doesn't want to take okay so I'll play
too much seven I'm gonna have to take at
some point I'll keep keeps putting my
pieces on better squares no now I'll
take this this open a files I can
probably he'll take on up five now I
don't know for sure of this and now he's
trying to do something here with rookie
to complete work update 24 and I'm going
to take so if you take so play Bishop g4
they take on e4 I'll take on h3 it plays
h4 probably queen up four so that I can
play Queen on 3 shock or coming up one
shock whoops I did I just miss that I
did oh of it takes six there should be
four up to h5 d 6
six sighs what's he threatening here oh
that was a now H four important stop
stop King g3 and now this is check and
now he's just lost it and that's again
okay so two nights tingled win by force
Saul tonight of 333 Bishop g2 play a
Catalan against them this time see what
you want to do probably a six which one
oh I'll play the old man line up a can
play Bishop d2 like cuz farm used to do
back in the old old old days rare case
751 for Queen c16 play Knight 3 3
did I just pull under here I'm getting
without c-5m not ideal okay I'll take a
look upon which we three hmm
guys this isn't really hot as opposed to
play this on anyway click Queen d2 d3
Knight f4 I'm just going to put a knight
on d3 one way or another
put a knight on d3 and basically make
him prove that the extra bonus is worth
lot or that he has good technique this
still is not not trivial to block blocks
up a pond but it's opposite color bishop
so I'm going to play up for next we will
open wide act lights for diagonal so he
wants to exchange all the let in
exchange for I could have taken on c7
too but I think I think this point I'm
down upon it's a little bit hard to be
overly optimistic and play for play for
play at all costs so if he wants if he
wants to make a draw you can make a draw
but all I'll make improve it so we
should have 6 interesting move now this
is interesting now I'm going to take and
exchange the rooks now I can't really
want to play it like this this is very
interesting and I see spies Queen b6 so
nice B sub would make them make them
exchange everything on this is a very
interesting position because here we're
both a double on these this kind of deep
on can become good might also be bad as
well so because it's if Queen c4 I'll
just click clean b1 and now the queen
queen isn't actually doing anything so
now I can just kicking with b3 bring my
queen to e2 and say what are you doing
over here it is there there is no actual
right here so I'm going to get
aggressive here I'm going to get really
aggressive and try to do something
so let's do we want to do so Chuck and
King Fe
interesting and interesting now I can
plate Queen H 87-95 woo this looks quite
dangerous but now I'm starting to clean
up six chuck the square on f6 could just
feel like game over in fact I think it
very well might be game over so it's so
Queen c7 that that holds at least
temporarily so I'll throw in an ultra on
a couple checks try to gain a little bit
of time maybe up thighs maybe just hey
just aged for maybe just play moves play
simple waiting moves maybe Queen g8 was
the move that I was missing the Queen
g18 e6 and Queen e8
now that might have been the way to
proceed although Queen d6 here I have 93
- so okay so he plays tini so in fact he
actually walks right into what I was
hoping for so now I'll check enough eyes
so okay so what's the threat he doesn't
have a threat I can play Knight up three
here threaten something maybe not
threaten anything play night at seven
this looks reasonable
now throw on a check
to me for a while okay so can i gah I am
take P to okay so now let's see okay
second
now I need to think % 96 can be 395 if
you choose me for can be to I think I
will play a night up 3 to attack this
pawn here on c2 here d2 very important
now I can escape and I can take and now
he's too slow just losses by public on
p4 oh yeah why not let's play the tango
again since it worked last game keep the
streak laws play okay I'll play e5 here
so deep line I see something that's
going to turn something h4 fo we can
move play ok h5 why not now so this
would be 4 FS there should be particle
tank play d6 I'm just going to move my
queen next move get out of this nasty
pen or play Knight f8 night eh
seven-mile Ice Queen d7 so now I can
move that Knight to g4 next move and so
it's the LD and that won't touch it
Connelly this is the shirt h3 I'll play
Knight g4 4
so Queen c2 I complete cleanup 5a thing
looks completely fine
it takes pigs if you move tonight H to
lose an ID to even I'll just retreat my
bishop or maybe even this episode's here
for why bother just just simple moves
like this would be something make a lot
of sense if a chief or I'll take Bishop
g2 five six is going to Bishop probably
III maybe maybe d2 but it anyway blacks
into this line these double bonds are
quite quite bad so I'm going to fix it
so we number at c5 Kingi to just I'll
finish my development what's this now I
want to attack this Ponce and maybe I
should is there some way to attack this
pawn if I could get my Knight to d7 oh
the ideal so I'm going to actually play
some really deep ideas here and try to
do something over put my works here the
fish left side so if you want to
exchange you can probably will go back
now I do it e4 yeah why not play e4 and
create this square for the knight now
Bishop e2 I go g5 I'm in everything's
terrible here it's bishops are just
really really bad now crashing throne
the H file as well so
so let's see so
so let's do it so you please see five so
it's finally desperation time so I can
take the beep on but I think I'll take
this way just to keep the D file close
so take egg takes the fish should be two
now I can play working as showing play
Knight f3 also I have three looks might
make the task more difficult but I think
that this has to be winning technically
so it's just a question of how to
convert so don't play Bishop c8 oh I
worked you to me your work g2 is maybe
simpler
yeah this was this was actually simplest
I should have done this right away just
on work h1 I go g3 so work up one now I
played this basic and come after this
pawn to e5 level steak x1 I'll display
if I play g3e six kimchi six looks
winning yeah II 16 to 6 and of e sub and
I just take up to a chop
take and now there are many ways to win
there should be five I think I'll just
track and play there should be five not
snow so I'll give them one more game
probably and then I think I'm going to
move on so I'll play I'll stick to what
I've been feeding them with so far I'll
keep playing the same thing probably say
another cattle and give them another
shot redeem themselves so that last
thing is not good so let's say Queen c2
something different different line at
least of the cattle and let's see what
he wants to do c6 is what Magnus played
against it's not considered to be the
best move
so this is a six that especially is
weird flavor p1 please work c8 probably
I play Queen 84 or just III I think d3
is correct so on c5 I'll just take d5
and I'll click vision v2
CGT 494 if he takes and I take DC for
Lenny it's done on 96 and also
threatening night up slides maybe okay
so it plays b5 it's a reasonable move um
I feel like I think I've actually had
something very similar to this maybe
this in fact is like one of the games
that I've actually played before as a
black this looks a lot like a game I had
against crops and cows but it could be
slightly different as well so I'll play
I play Knight f5 see what he wants to do
Bishop c5 and play like rook d1 oh it
should be forward that's a strange
that's all in a three now if he takes
I'll take back because then I is this
this this trip of 97 also on carlee's
Bishop c5 this was the right links now I
also have Queen g5 coming too so so not
only do I have a Queen g5 here um which
might just be winning Queen g5 g6
98 98 is a move I guess 98 Knight h6 th8
okay Queen three five ninety eight six
to twenty five ninety eight ninety
seventy eighty eight and somehow I don't
have a me so I think I'm just going to
play simple truss I'm just going to
check and take take the I just take the
exchange and play like Queen 85 or maybe
even I'll just take on c4 probably
simpler just take on c4 although in this
game I am down on time so it is fairly
important that I move fast now
so Ruby seven put pressure on these
nights since they're kind of misplaced
or not misplaced they aren't they aren't
really helping each other here so try to
put pressure on the knife and then um
use these two bishops but especially the
fishbone is diagonal so Queen c5 says
here I could take I tend notice what
he's counting on so I'm not going to
take and give him some c3 stuff even a
lot was completely winning I'm just
going
they were key one and play simple shots
here so kimchi ate so he's really
begging me to take and if I take his
seat tree is that what he's banking on
I'm confused
no he's not okay so I was taking place
III Bishop c1 and under selva P is here
and this is completely winning now tried
it simplifies and come down on time so
yeah after this one I will move on class
and then I'll just see is Erik sitting
there and waiting if you lurking looks
like he is okay so routiers with the
bishop here so I can play Bishop c2 also
stops or if d1 played Bishop c2 just
stops any stuff here and probably next
movie on I'll just play work d1 forcing
the move is rook off the file now
Liberty 500 but also a rook c5 just keep
it simple keep it simple rotate to a
five is winning as well but Merc c5 just
winds on the spot isn't he's forced to
exchange the rooks then next move is
Bishop the orbit takes e3 so okay I
think it's time let's let's see what
does a is Eric wanted a you want to play
okay so the real match is be gone okay
Knight f3 air it's going to play
differently today
okay so blissed-out the first like ten
moves castles there should be seven I
don't know look see one is b4 is a
little bit weird on so here I can play
c4 no no it's a good move I'll try it
I'll try to make this game really
interesting if you take typing we need
five or ninety five or both pause going
I'll just quickly make five now nice
before I'll just take the pawn in a
three on 85
85 Seattle take probably will take
Brooke c1 all this take on c3 so takes
takes 95 probably 95 er I don't have to
probably so let's see so here we go
display fish and b-sides fish about
three probably just a six or something
just doesn't be careful not to get my
queen trapped over here okay so he plays
up three now let's see now I can play d4
I guess or not I think all this else a
simple knows fish would be 748 try to
put pressure maybe d4 at some point 9h
fives also what a lot of options so now
he's trying to threaten rook a 1 so I
can play Queen b3 need to make it force
a draw it's not really what I want to do
on but if I click Queen b3 if it's not I
need to think of that so if I click
Queen b3 Queen d2 and okay he plays rook
e1 so let's see 12.9 h5 for this page
six
alright please repeat one okay
interesting
okay so I will play Bishop so goodness
well click assured c6 I'll give them on
giving the pawn here
probably he'll take maybe not maybe I
mean where k1 could be a problems but
Russia see so what's his next move
probably he'll take I would assume but
I'm not sure okay so it plays f4 so what
you want to sleep your g4 now so now
it's time to do something and in a hurry
so if I play Knight f6 probably just
take home c6 if I move my Bishop g4 g4
could be a problem
let's see okay so clean ain't a stakes
okay I've kind of just gotta move now
so okay so d5 58 I don't know what he's
doing because something you loving back
into the game it's just much better now
it's not it's not trivial at all
actually
so I'm down on tying there's I'm a
student at so I'm gonna play e6 try to
pry break this pawn structure change
things up a little bit so now maybe
ninety seven is an idea to because the
vision before also Nike seven thank you
take or what's that now I can okay I can
kc5 I want to be practical I'm just
going to take and take on your eyes and
place III and try it try a really put
pressure on the UH violinist I mrs.
Queen this uh this um no that just hangs
me that was that now that just hangs the
peace there so okay so it starts off
with a walkie one time to feed enough
probably I so just taking the exchange
when would have been it's a real trouble
um let's see okay
there should be four nine ninety-two
just Bishop you to in castles probably I
should have moved faster that I was a
little bit too slow don't play h3g for
for if you please be five just makes you
three probably see five up five
hopefully h4 just to create a square for
my create square for my Bishop possibly
later on if it's necessary d5 I'll take
eg five and I'll play I'll just play off
stuck just just this force the action
the night night - sighs - buff for also
dish before anyway here to d4 reasonable
play ninety-four it takes I'll take
so works eh I'll just play nine three
eight three protect the night here on e4
probably uh move the bishop but Queen b6
also means no maybe I should try h5 I
don't actually know that makes sense but
I think I'll play theater just stop 94
stop any 94 93 stuff Bishop update I'll
play h5 try to open it up now a little
bit 95 I will take
90s books I think are just a queen d4
issues if I might just a queen d4 here
that's why not I don't see why it
doesn't work no let's play Queen g1
Queen up to a lot of 94 so just queen g1
move the Queen back on so wants to go
for some mates off forward here salt
over k e1 maybe and it looks reasonable
enough so queen g4 I'll play clean h2
now all the other thing is maybe if I
get like two moves I'm threatening to
like play legwork III work age three and
just Nathan and a couple of moves cells
might be an idea
okay thrifty for I'll play rook III
because now I want now I want to create
some kind of mates rights here so so I
can play ninety-two here um I can also
just take maybe or take on c5 there are
a lot of takes here okay so click clean
c8 so takes work e5 c5 Knight f5 or just
Knight a5 right away maybe a Knight f5
right away 94 95 94 work e8 okay so I'll
take actually nice you for it can also
maybe just like this takes be solvent as
well so it takes so isn't he just out of
down a piece here or microfiche ePHI it
should be positive you - okay so I see
what he's trying to do okay so I will
okay you can click new G to assume
anything exam and takes takes I should
be fine it can lose the Queen just 92
probably I'm sure 90 there were some
other way to pledge more precisely than
what I did but not a whole lot of time
on the clock in d7 yeah now I owe it 92
is actually got to be careful so
actually no 94 is 94 that's one I take
the bishop with tempo on fish about
dates I'll play what will I play maybe
c3
Tirion now I'll just take and plate
their stage two and basically now
everything's safe and secure over here
on the on the on the kingside oh that
that was not a very good move actually
let's try and be a little bit more
careful three
I'll give them a check on the back or in
second just with my king on 295 it's got
to be a little bit careful here okay
what am i doing think too slow again in
this game as well I don't know why I'm
so slowly this game
terrible terrible terrible terrible
terrible too slow too laggy now okay
all right I'm going to beat him five in
a row now so so soft soft stop talking
so much are in the game schools clearly
using too much time getting too low so
I'm gonna have to feel a little bit less
chatty for the next couple of games so
for sure I was winning that loss on some
point just to complicate and not getting
too low on time rolling so let's say I
can get two nights five try to do
something over here on the team side
before you can expand okay six see three
probably just c58 for Emily for is this
place
a
so it says x6 III this place e5b for a
clean c3 probably just work a 2 or just
speed before they took probably work 80
to 93 94 I don't know if this works but
seems like it's worth a shot
wait what
how would I just hang that mm and this P
7.0 k1 okay so they take seasick night
at 47 between g5g three okay let's see
the tape c6 d 424 all right - 4 C 725
and it's the g3
maybe d-4d three share I think I'll try
the beef or maybe B 3 B 4 B 3 so that
he's going to do so C 6
- oh he's nice III Oh yikes
XO it's not good okay um very careless
okay probably this is lost but maybe
there's some hope of something
oh wait oh just taken Oh am i stupid
oh and of course you suck or not it's
the wrong position it doesn't work yeah
it's not gonna work okay okay
[Music]
so okay now I'm just not going to talk
period
clearly not focusing enough bomb so come
on Eric move okay play the same nice
seven for councils
need to be fast fast if or maybe I'll
take on d5 maybe not
tics 85-95 and probably c4 display c-47
clean - if he plays worth DHS rip d1
about the roof d1 fish up here on b8 is
is pretty bad probably just work e1 next
he doesn't have a throat with fish about
541 protect everything
now if syrian complain 94 I don't know
if I want to to move this point h5 suits
getting desperate here trying to open
this off um yeah I think I will assuming
it doesn't hang something C which it
doesn't appear to hang anything
it's a d4 normal play h4 side dish page
394 just kim joo-won sir 58 off the dish
page 3 force the Queen off the square
and then maybe s3 maybe not but I'm not
sure those playoffs three be safe
prophylactic there should be six maybe
Bishop c1 become G 597 I can take I
think this bakery makes more sons now 95
I'll just take the Queen's it - maybe
okay wants to play Knight up eight
tonight update after threatened I don't
know so see five minutes twenty four
ninety five 24 probably or 95 maybe I'll
maybe I'll just take even ok so taste BC
5 it's a very weird no 96 rip C 1 C 6
also different b2 b4 was also move the
knight a 392 for now now I'm just going
to start putting on the clock on the
board just to see one probably try to do
something over here on the King side and
I'll bring the knight back to be 5
ressy one also how's 95 X 196 time
to resign Erik 96 um a x64 try to put
some pressure on these this King side
over here well I realize I had clean b5
right away okay it's a roof v8 and I
will play rook e1 I'm just going to play
for up for now this platform is blasted
open okay I'll take you should see seven
and take I don't have to I think oh this
let's play e5 95 different you to
probably or just work c5 just be fast
and blow them off the boards and take a
condition d7 at the end instead of deep
dish should be 855 a 66 coming as well
and that's one
a free I'll just play a five here soften
[Music]
okay gonna play this one tonight get to
all play d5 it takes take 93 97 Bishop
d2 on strength of 187 9406
b4 I think I just take and play a four
I'm forgetting how this line goes which
I could so there should be three or a
three was maybe better maybe I don't
know maybe a through this better but
anyway this position still is completely
climb for blacks h4 else like maybe
seventh h5 probably all this take on or
just Queen B five ports
um so this is d2l display Brooke CA try
to control both these open files here
the a file in the C file just to provide
anything on it cooks like Queenie six
here I don't really like it who wants to
go this page three I get it I'll play
anything I don't really know if this is
the best move but I'll try it anyway
just to force an exchange takes Bishop
age three Knight f5 again I control both
the C file I mean I control though this
the C file and the a file so that's very
important in this position that I that I
control both the files can be 102 h6 to
stop an h e5 and now fish page three
just f5 f5 it's a strong period um it
should be for don't explain I see five I
want to 95 92 48 I don't see it so makes
sense 96 48 looks pretty good
okay so Queen b3 um I'll just take and
Playworks be to just try and put that
maximum pressure on who's a king side
here in fact it's very close to losing
here so I'm trying to just like f5 and
dish about date maybe or something so
I'll play
what will I play here I'll just play a
592 g5 maybe yeah it looks good looks as
good as anything else 96 of them is just
logged off 824 Queen b6 which would be 5
CH 7
yeah I don't see it so ok Queen B one
eye is clean the one okay so the game
continues up its rook c5 make 94 g5 now
I'm going to play chief for probably in
fact now we could work on a7 I can also
swing it all the way over here too
q1 I work eight seven maybe four maybe G
for my lifework age seven seems like a
good move try and create threads here on
the kingside maybe g4f or just try and
really just smash them over here so we
need to does not threaten anything so
I'll just grab this pawn we 1/8 is not
threaten anything so it works e5 and d5
next or works the HS to cut them off b5
looks good enough though for some bath
of G for play c8 me or maybe now I'll
switch I think I'll play with d7 here
just switch back the other way
negative 5 all this tape and if you take
that little rocky one shot and if he
does something else 96 all this Toronto
check anyway
and now just not to hang something
stupid so six cakes and okay okay so all
all pretty random still on six off the
Queenie to probably work t1 next move or
clean up one two all the fun to nine a
for now
so queen seven now I can take on d5 or
maybe takes 95 what am I missing so take
take take take
I mean not missing anything necessarily
but I'll just play see for just keep it
simple
see for just take time d4 I have Knight
b6 maybe or do I just want to play rook
c1 or 92 probably 92 mix I think YouTube
is base seven could be okay maybe just
to see five of course to stop this d5
nonsense um and also not an 8b 6
- yeah c5 actually it was pretty obvious
- to waste so much time I'll not move
let's see
so maybe 95 95 92 maybe I think it makes
sense just to play for 94 94 I think the
sack on i-4 doesn't quite work although
I'm sure he's probably considering it
right now but it doesn't look to me like
it quite works if I had to guess but
I'll make the premium just in case he
does it no he did it sure enough okay so
clean up 3 there should be 5 I'll take
efore probably I just take this is going
to get messy but I don't think that's
quite works for him
probably he has to play e4 as equal I
will pay it takes wait what am i what am
I missing
so takes f3 kimchi one I'm not up a
piece on this up of piece I've just got
two pieces here right takes takes just 2
pieces for the rook maybe 96 was better
than Bishop chief then this takes up 3
but ok but this is pretty good I'm just
I've got two pieces for the UH for the
exchange here now I think 96 is in order
when I see six foursome to take and then
then the c4 pawn becomes very weak as
well okay so this should be six I'll
play Ricky one yeah Eric kind of went
wrong I think it was very it was very
very interesting he'd played this a
different way but now and just played
Bishop g2 I guess just protect
everything no Turkey for was also
probably working for his native the
spotter but okay I guess he's going to
lose a bishop I should probably make
this pre move on so he plays g5 okay now
if maybe just just play c6 maybe takes
Bishop e3 just really ugly and now I
think just fish bait three take take
take
taken not just game over so proficient
v6 I came to cakes I take cake Nazi
seven wins t-72 swims right nice see it
nice see it also just went so they both
when I I don't want to risk may be
overlooking something simple so so so
let's say I'll stick to the same thing
and will play another bought thinning
b1d 63 this is 681 so yeah we're just
going to play the same same system
against in IE 2 82 97 ok so we're going
to literally play the same system I got
ok let's see what is improvement is fun
so there should be 3 wow the actual
include the same line again
interesting I didn't didn't believe in
this for white so I'm a little bit
surprised he's going to play the same
line this is surprising it's a 96 ok
reasonable move this Queen e6 maybe or
Vichy 5 - v 5 nice before I'm assuming
that's his plan but I don't understand
are to believe in this this this idea
that Eric's plan I mean virtually 7 was
maybe also just possible but anyway
we'll see this should see 6 so I can
take if I want to I don't think I want
to take I think I just want to play
queen g4 94 probably queen g4 Knights 42
doesn't quite work when you're 394 takes
takes takes takes takes doesn't really
something very optimal so I'll just
click Queen b8 I guess now nice before
just my bishop back to f6 probably it's
not not ideal but not not terrible
either
there's about three I can play Queen d7
here maybe just newest rookie a force 96
or I was clicking to solving something
simple simple and safe so I still
control it's a file so they're there no
threats down the a file and down the a
line on h4 now I'll click we do solvent
I'll give them I'll give them this case
takes tape I'll give them this b6 pawn
but if so this would be to know if like
we need six h5 them I'm probably going
to take but I'm not sure I don't have to
so maybe maybe just Knight f5 just the
simple moves keep to keep the tension
going in addition because there's no
need to do on no need to do anything
insane here so let's see on to Queen B
one I don't know Queen B want to have
Knight d6 maybe now I don't want to do
that I'll just play maybe work c8 he
wants to go Bishop c6 again is what I
think
close play rip d8 simple maybe 96 is an
idea next move maybe not I'm not not
sure
okay the cleanup once again I will say
Knight d6 not all I'll force them to
decide how I wants to play this 628 I
actually forgot about each sex I have to
say which was sign now if I take rook
656 it's the eight work d8 I'm still
kind of holding on I can also play
Bishop da Navy risky to play different
e8 in this position on probably all this
repeat and I don't really want to repeat
but it's probably too dangerous to nog
repeat so I mean
this would be 8 there should be 4 yeah I
don't I don't see it so listen I repeat
yeah cleanup 595 yeah I'm not saying it
fine I'll just force it wrong yeah okay
yeah right so I'll stop there from from
playing he file I'll just I'll play what
I did yesterday work so well those night
up three different six ticks ticks just
going to go D 392 maybe e4 maybe III not
sure yet okay five a3 probably Bishop e6
probably now I'll play e4 Queen to
threaten e5 v for you five castles or
key 851 now I'll see maybe night update
maybe this now if I want to I want to
play this
I'll fireworks t1 to t4 now I can play a
fourth I want to h4 seems like the more
practical move to play and well I'm a
die I would like to thank the people who
have donated I keep hearing this
clicking sound every so they're not
clicking this up ringing sound every
soft and so thanks to all of you out
there who have made donations so far
I've been teak and I'll just take on c5
and 5c3 just flat this make maybe take
the rough actually makes more Sun
okay so Queen d7 night up 3v4 I'll just
take in Playworks we force a knight b3
but the good move I come in I overlook
that um I should not overlook that 100
capital Quincy to be for probably I take
on before maybe we'll see six a little
bit little bit strange on 38 okay so if
d8 now maybe we're doing one I don't
know if I'm actually going to play d4
just like work c6 big R if you want seem
like a practical move to on try and
create some an eletric c6 since the
Queen's on a sovereign I just want
Knight a5
then I can maybe take on d6 and
ninety-five gets Messier gun
so rookie southern now surely okay d4
doesn't work and I don't know what will
work pigs
Bishop g3 should I kind of saw this but
Dave we forgot about it
[Music]
that was stupid
um let's see okay so or they take 94 if
I play rook c8 rook c8 Queen CA probably
I have to try this even though it's not
not really what I wanted to do takes
takes is probably just come back with
Queen c2 and just pretend that nothing
happened something like that um Bishop
a4 I can just take on p5 and now I have
96 coming it's not so bad it's not as
bad as it looked actually so out of 96
probably work d8 Brookes somewhere when
you listen riff I play e5 so it doesn't
look like he has any other moves that
are playable um probably he has some of
those ropes not so e5 Knight 7 I can
play a six if I want to
doesn't seem right somehow I feel like
there's got to be something better here
like see 695 but I don't actually see it
so I'm gonna have to try it and I don't
have all the time the world's eggs
finish seven on maybe twenty two and our
teams you two is right or not probably
wasn't rise but the bottom move so since
and also dishes you sick so that I can
head some efficiency five yeah there we
go
all right
Oh
okay so let's see I'm going to play
another bought dinner he actually is
this is surprising Eric seems determined
to prove that this line is fine for ye I
don't actually think it is but we'll see
okay okay so I work eight seven again
like just like before um now what did i
do laughing I don't actually remember so
you want something I see sighs okay
click this so if I play rook c7 let's
see okay I'll just play Queen d7 now
there should be six and I can play bro
case seven I think
and if you take I take Queen before wiki
eight and we've put were something
pretty similar to what we just had so H
four play rook rook c8 oops night I
thought oops oops oops up so that was
that that was Knight a5
I she is just my taste of seven put
maybe not so bad cleanup 755 96
it could be worse it could be a lot
worse though I didn't miss this when I
played work c8 I forgot that um that he
had this idea but anyway the game goes
on and actually it's probably not so bad
take pics okay so you doesn't want to do
that's official there should be four uni
dish about date night at 7:00
is that so I'll just play Knight h6 also
now I'm threatening a rook C 194 amongst
other little little odds and ends
Bishop c6 now I'll try to exchange the
dark square Bishop s'
this would be to maybe just queen e7
attack this on an e2 94 maybe wants to
go Bishop g5 maybe we need 6 Bishop b5
is bad so maybe just pissin he4 I've got
to be careful about with the time
situation here sufficient g5 cleaning 6
Bishop b5 cleanup 5 seems seems fine
wait what
this is the southern I've oh geez visual
covers that square ie a I like just
Bishop covers c1 mmm probably 25 there
should be south ah but he is there would
be southern anyway so it doesn't quite
work see ya
these 641 probably night have sex at
some point on some point someday p5 93
Queen c7 all this take maybe five it was
just pretty good there should be four
Cleo 13s or Ricky one maybe plus Ricky
one problem threatens and kind of sack
here on y 8 and if he goes like fish for
update I can maybe just when I take D
five as well so this is pretty pretty
ugly or black here b6
well let's click clean up 3:30 p7 I just
take and Bishop exile 6 and then d4 19
slides just winning
so we'll see what he wants to do Queen
b6 right a5 b5 does not make sense there
any way to punish him here
fortunately doesn't look like it g4 g5
now probably that's way too extravagant
a5 b5 probably there isn't so probably I
just have to play simple moves
unfortunately it's double the rooks and
place them in like I don't know h3 maybe
well I don't really want to take with us
pawn on always taking the rook and now
I'll take this I mean this isn't really
what I was hoping for but it's still
still some kind of advantage it's not
much but it's something all right final
play Nike - I just want to play Knight
f3 maybe exchange nice take advantage of
this these weaknesses over here it's 97
I'll take and now I'll play make you one
probably be three night up to 93
something along these lines is what I
want to do ideally in a perfect world
probably not going to get that but the
bishop c6 and now let's see now I can
play like b3 maybe just b3 problem and
if you Casey still has this weakness
here on b6 we've exchanged since the
bishops it's 94 all tonight a4 and now
I'm threatening also to just take upon a
d6 again
now maybe it's better not not to play
Knight up for me there's something
better than no but at any rate we'll say
I'm just going to go back for some 95
tricks again 95 I'll play we knock one I
think at 96 made Queen 96
additionally acre or 95 maybe not sure
um I'll just play from now three I'll
give them an extra move and now took
took off took some of the time off the
clock and now I can blitz em again
and she's also running at a time time
issues here synoptic Queen c6 tried to
force an exchange of Queens take and now
Queenie 232 and g5 627
alright
see all 84 actually he hasn't been
playing e4 we going to play d4 no he's
not okay is Eric play listen playing was
weird rubbish with Bishop C forum of
three so I wasn't sure
okay wants to do this at least this is a
little bit different this isn't this
isn't a standard now so this should be
interesting at least play Knight f6
s5 meeting nice sees me just 97 96 just
King update and I'm not really sure what
the Knights are knighted and the
necklace type codfish pops its new g3 g6
not really sure
kind of a weird position so I'm gonna
play h5 in probably 94 to special be 7
play Knight f6 absolute now I'll go
different e6 copy uh okay is no Bishop
out for now and what's it's not I'm 94
maybe um I don't know if I want to take
I can definitely take her to h4 work x5
maybe it's all kind of a little bit
weird on fine with all I'll just take
I'll take in Philippines e7 play true
true traditional variations on a c4
Knight g4 probably
I'm cheese free maybe h4 maybe I'm not
sure if I will do that but probably I
will G 3 H 4 and there should be 2 I
just take on g 3v takes i take on h4 if
he takes of 94
obviously I take cakes ok so let's not
play Knight f6 maybe I can also maybe
play takes rook h1 and maybe or I can
take and maybe play on Knight up to or
night of 2 right away
I think I'll just take now I think maybe
I should play route gates 1 and Knight
f6 seems reasonable why not let's let's
do is going to do here so I'll check
kingi to obviously on Knight of 6
now let's see I mean maybe Ricky -
rookie - maybe queen c6 or do I not have
time for Queen - six here 2015 h1 I
don't actually have time for so I guess
I lost a little gauge 5 so d4 I'll take
a queen bee for just Bishop c5 probably
or work d8 maybe maybe just work da this
is very dangerous position for white to
be in here um it's also a lot harder to
play for white them for black
so if there's just be two probably I
mean I has many different moves I'm
probably my main strike here is Bishop
takes g3 is there should be three I mean
I can play this take g3 I think I don't
know if I want it clean c6 looks really
really strong I don't actually see an
answer to this Queen to rook h2 Chuck
idea
I'm just running work h2 and Queen takes
up three because it's this 10 here on
this diagonal and I think this might
just be losing I mean ref do you want
fine an hour h2 and clean up stereo and
I think it's just just over LA so
alright let's see so fine I have three
again III probably probably hopefully
about five again same thing takes
takes a 5 a 3 and some c4 sub 96 is
interesting I wasn't really expecting
that c6 I'll play e4 probably I'll play
e5 at some point maybe like right away
in fact I'm just going to try and do
something slow over here on the King's
IV so it's not quite so clear what
blacks where blacks play is here on the
queen size of b4 b5 Wow okay now I think
this is really dangerous for plot
because after I play up for I'm just
I've got a free hand here on the UH on
the King side Saul hey GSX okay
interesting
um so I can play h5 I can play like I go
to be quick here because he is his plans
are pretty straightforward um pleat
chief or maybe I think I will play chief
or I don't know if it's good but seems
interesting at least to try and
basically play up five and just lock
this whole position down here so he's
going to play up five to five and then
the game continues on
submission d6 okay so I can play h5
maybe I don't know if I want to I don't
want to play efficiency one Knight f3
just just keep everything stall as I can
I don't really want to play h5 I think
I'm going to do it though to ricochet to
h6 th7 and crime has become rather Josh
because a block Queen side but neither
there's still some chance that I don't
know maybe maybe I can get something
over here like a sack on g6 at some
point I'm just going to try to redevelop
my pieces put them on some awesome
squares me like c3 because the night is
not good here on c7 so maybe just like
c3 Ricky - Ricky - and I just just kind
of just we all those of that looks he
had on Queen c7 but now I'll make sure
that he doesn't get Queen c7 will
calligraphy to see - and now 14 g3 to
stop any tricks over here and now I have
to kind of come up with something so
let's see so I'll open my work over here
I'll all dissolve everything maybe I'm
not going to get that chance
unfortunately so I'll take BC 4 ok but
now after rookie - maybe maybe they can
get something here actually because now
I'm 96 595 Orion d5 maybe ah here's
Knight d6 of course obviously and now
it's just solutions kind of too close
I'll try to take and do something here
but it's very unlikely that I can
yeah it's going to be too hard to do
anything so probably just move on to the
next game that is I mean I don't know
unless he doesn't want maybe wants to
play on here or is he thinking or is he
flagging yeah so alright so um okay so
this is thought this is probably going
to be laughing that I play for now on I
think there's another show coming up on
trust constants so I'll probably cut it
off here so that everyone can watch that
that show next time so this should be
the last game so Bishop c4 awfully
similar to what I did laughing maybe
make it interesting
okay so here if I play d5 maybe it's bad
I'm not sure
fishing seven Bishop e3
Knight up scut 97 I'm just gonna play
Knight f6 Oh Castle if you take so I'll
probably take it the night I'm not
really sure
Oh desolate sliver of p8 probably Knight
up one something there's going to be
something really slow unfortunately
something which is going to be horribly
exciting most likely for a last game but
I'll try to make it exciting so there
should be six I wanted to probably play
Knight f5 okay so he does take so now I
have a choice I'm just going to take the
knight and probably put this knight on
e4 probably this would be four or 94
also possible move I'm just broke d8 put
everything in the center here where
there are no weaknesses probably Bishop
e5 looks fine
there should be four now maybe I'll play
g6
hey 45 90 for this rookie yay
pretty boring pretty worn but let's see
so I guess Texas I'm threatening night
up to or night geeks you all know night
probably nicest night takes up to is a
simple threat um so maybe he'll take on
e4 maybe not maybe Queen b3 maybe Queen
d3 hard to play maybe it's fine on maybe
Knight f3 also possible is in the deep
tank though so let's see so plenty to
okay so the normal that I really
consider a new Knight g4 here I didn't
go play Knight g4 trying to make this as
spicy as complicated as possible since
it is last game as well so I'll try to
make it interesting might backfire
spectacularly but let's see so um
[Music]
nothing any questions lately but puts
lately laid aside so f3 if I tape whoa
can't I just take on e5 and meet him
oh wait he's fq4 nice I'm not hanging on
oh is that too for anything on by a
miracle okay so it's hanging on by a
miracle so I can play 92 or chuckling up
to 92 probably just 92 right away and
this again it's very hard to play this
mission and hope for much but work up
one no I will just take the pawn on g4
you know - I can play work u7m 1887 d4
looks pretty good create 7d for Queen be
a king g7 Queen g3 take take take takes
better better on game at least so cheats
h3 also in g5 take B for anyway
so he is using a lot of time here I must
say debating whether to take the pond
although now if he takes the pond maybe
I even a rookie - so I assume I assume
he's going to take the partner I would
assume but I'm not sure hope it's yeah
so he does take the pawn to d4 Queen B
18 to 7 Brook up - not d3 the move D
takes c3 is also and probably I just
take though and play like Queen c5 make
sense just threatened threatened rook e1
Chuck and now I can just take this pawn
and he can take that one on rookie 4
okay I'll check and I'm going to go
rookie 7 again anyway yeah I think he's
busted here King King eh eh - rookie 7
and I don't see how to protect all he
feels he can't protect this 107
now so I think that should be it so yeah
alright so okay you guys I guess that's
going to be the last game for now umm I
don't know what I'll do another one
probably not for a while since I do this
thing called Cup coming up but anyway I
hope you guys enjoyed it even if I even
if I let Eric win a few more than and he
probably should have um but but I'm sure
I'll be back again soon I hope you guys
enjoyed it so until the next time
everyone thanks following thanks for
their nations and looking forward to
being back here again soon and hopefully
winning some more games against the air
so that's all for now so take care
everyone have a good evening - week week
and weekend and all these accidents so
bye